[Aplausos]
[Música]
en este vídeo amigos de visual política
vamos a echar un vistazo a la
trayectoria de quien casi seguro es uno
de los personajes más controvertidos y
sorprendentes de lo que llevamos de
siglo
hablamos de mijaíl saakashvili
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un momento no le conoces pues imagínate
un personaje que es al mismo tiempo uno
de los mejores aliados de washington y
el mayor enemigo de vladimir putin un
personaje capaz de haber sido presidente
de un país aspirante a la presidencia de
otro y que hoy carece incluso de
nacionalidad alguna un hombre un
político un personaje propio de novelas
de intriga política y misterio un tipo
amigos cuyas hazañas parecen parte de un
guión para alguna superproducción de
netflix de hecho ahora que lo digo no me
extrañaría nada que se acabe haciendo
algo así
[Música]
pues bien todo esto es nuestro
protagonista de hoy mijaíl saakashvili
no es la primera vez que le mencionamos
aquí en visual político hablamos sobre
él ya en uno de nuestros primeros vídeos
uno que hicimos sobre la revolución de
las rosas por cierto en la descripción
os dejo el enlace no está mal verdad 7
añitos desde luego aquellos vídeos eran
un pelín diferentes a los de ahora
estábamos empezando así que ya se sabe y
desde luego por aquel entonces esta
comunidad de visual politiquera mucho
muchísimo más pequeña cómo han cambiado
las cosas así que ante todo muchas
gracias a todos los que estáis suscritos
a este canal y hacéis posible que este
proyecto crezca y crezca de verdad
gracias pero dicho esto volvamos al
bueno de misa que es como se conoce a
este personaje y al que muchos
consideran como la mano política de
washington en el antiguo espacio
soviético vamos allá
[Música]
misa el gobernador
para comenzar nuestra historia tenemos
que remontarnos hasta el 30 de mayo de
2015 ese día petro poroshenko el
presidente de ucrania nombró a mijail
saakashvili gobernador de la provincia
de odessa junto al puesto de gobernador
a misa se le concedió la nacionalidad
ucraniana algo para lo cual saakashvili
tuvo que renunciar a la de su país natal
georgia cuyos destinos había dirigido
entre 2004 y 2013 el fichaje fue toda
una bomba mediática y no era para menos
veréis en aquel momento ucrania vivía un
estado de tensión enorme tras la llamada
revolución del maidán y la caída del
presidente ucraniano pro ruso víctor
yanukóvich acontecimientos de los que
por cierto ya os hemos hablado aquí en
este canal el país vivía una situación
prácticamente de guerra civil entre los
partidarios de kiev y los partidarios de
moscú y odessa era precisamente una de
las provincias más pro rusas así que ya
os podéis imaginar amigos que eso de
fichar a todo un ex presidente
extranjero tratándose encima de uno
los mayores enemigos de vladimir putin
fue un acontecimiento que copó espacios
en todos los medios de comunicación del
planeta el presidente de ucrania antiguo
compañero de universidad y viejo amigo
de misa por cierto petro poroshenko lo
calificó en aquel momento como el hombre
que hace posible lo imposible
menudo piropo verdad y es que en aquel
momento el ibi dio entre ambos parecía a
prueba de bombas pues bien la misión era
estabilizar odessa apuntalar el poder de
quieres perseguir la corrupción y poner
los cimientos que permitiesen que la
región prosperase para hacer todo ese
enorme trabajo
micha trajo consigo a muchos de sus
antiguos colaboradores en georgia se
rodeó también de muchos profesionales
jóvenes ucranianos a los que consideraba
limpios de corrupción como por ejemplo
juliá maru ceská una activista que se
hizo famosa precisamente aquí en youtube
con el vídeo yo soy ucraniana y además
de todo esto me saiz o incluso algún que
otro fichaje entre los opositores de
putin en rusia como fue
de la activista rusa mariana aydar que
ocupó el cargo ni más ni menos que de
vicegobernadora de odessa había mucho
trabajo que hacer y había que hacerlo
pronto así que dicho y hecho
[Música]
y nada más ponerse al frente de esa misa
puso en marcha una investigación
minuciosa para encontrar y castigar a
los funcionarios corruptos cambió a
prácticamente todos los mandos de la
administración simplificó el proceso
para crear empresas introdujo controles
independientes e incluso liberó para el
uso público playas que habían sido
ocupadas ilegalmente y ojo porque misa
tiene una curiosa forma de trabajar tan
efectiva como polémica si algo no
funciona y es corrupto lo disuelve hecha
a todos los trabajadores y lo vuelve a
montar de nuevo lo hizo en su tiempo
como presidente de georgia con la
mismísima policía de tráfico y amenazó
con hacerlo de nuevo en el puerto de
odessa que es el mayor puerto comercial
de ucrania y que era conocido por los
sobornos y los pagos a funcionarios de
las aduanas
tenemos que despedirlos a todos tenemos
130 nuevas personas son jóvenes y están
bien entrenados en los de antes no hay
ninguna esperanza al final sólo tuvo que
despedir a algunos responsables del
servicio de aduanas para que se frenase
la corrupción
varios empresarios señalaron que los
sobornos en el puerto
realmente se habían detenido en los
últimos meses principalmente porque la
gente tenía miedo de convertirse en la
próxima víctima de la guerra contra la
corrupción de saakashvili con tanto
cambio y gracias por supuesto a los
contactos del nuevo gobernador o de esa
empezó a recibir muy pronto ayuda de
eeuu y como me sanó se fiaba nada de la
policía lo primero fue montar una
especie de nueva policía independiente
para luchar contra la corrupción una
policía organizada y entrenada por el
mismísimo fbi y también la policía de
california vamos que nos puede parecer
que todo iba viento en popa verdad pues
que esperar un momento porque lo cierto
es que saakashvili y su equipo pronto se
dieron cuenta de que todo iba a ser
mucho más difícil de lo que habían
pensado el problema amigos es que lo de
sanz no era un campo de batalla entre
los seguidores de kiev y los seguidores
pro rusos sino un campo de batalla entre
el estado basado en la ley y el estado
de los grandes oligarcas que han
dominado ucrania
desde su independencia
[Música]
i
el reino de los oligarcas
y cada vez más expertos lo tienen claro
el mayor problema de ucrania su mayor
obstáculo no es rusia sino los oligarcas
ucrania amigos es algo así como un país
donde la corrupción está tan arraigada
que casi podemos hablar de una especie
de país feudal donde los nobles son por
supuesto los oligarcas que lo controlan
todo las empresas el poder político la
administración los medios de
comunicación prácticamente nada escapa a
su poder un poder que han consolidado a
base de dinero y miedo su grado de
impunidad es prácticamente total e
incluso policía al gobierno y jueces
forman parte de esta especie de juego y
esto es algo amigos que lleva siendo así
desde que ucrania alcanzó su
independencia pero a partir de la
revolución del maldad las cosas
empeoraron tras la caída del presidente
prorruso víctor yanukóvich y ante el
estado de conflicto civil que vivía el
país el nuevo gobierno se vio incapaz de
confiar ni en el ejército ni en la
policía dos instituciones corruptas
desorganizadas y mal equipadas
por eso tomó una decisión nombrar a
varios oligarcas gobernadores de las
regiones más vulnerables del país estos
oligarcas financiaron un ejército
privado pusieron a la policía bajo sus
órdenes con generosos salarios y
pusieron precio a la cabeza de cada
separatista si tal cual como lo
escucháis el gobierno puso a los
mafiosos directamente al frente de
varias gobernaciones fue el caso por
ejemplo de igor kolomoisky que fue
puesto al frente de mi propio trust una
de las provincias económicamente más
importantes del país si esta es amigos
la ucrania que se encontró mijaíl
saakashvili en ucrania no hay una sola
empresa estatal que no haya sido
usurpada por un clan u otro hay varas a
broma vicious ministro de economía y
comercio de lituania como os podéis
imaginar todos estos oligarcas no
recibieron con manos abiertas ni a misa
ni a su plan de reformas una vez incluso
le echaron de una entrevista de
televisión cuando sugirió que había que
encerrar a todos estos mafiosos recordad
que los medios son propiedad de los
el caso es que me dio pronto batalla
para tratar de terminar con esta
situación
[Música]
haré lo que sea necesario para obtener
una victoria completa y librar a ucrania
de esta inmundicia de esta corrupta
escoria que capitaliza la sangre de
nuestros soldados y cuya única
motivación en la vida es llenar sus
propios bolsillos fortalecer su propio
plan y sangrar a ucrania hasta dejarla
seca y dicho y hecho
misa empezó a denunciar públicamente y
sin tapujos todo tipo de tráficos de
influencia tratos de favor y privilegios
en una ocasión por ejemplo fue a la
televisión nacional y denunció con todo
lujo de detalles una corruptela que
hacía que las aerolíneas de colom o ins
que tuvieran privilegios casi de
monopolio en muchos vuelos del país
la denuncia pública terminó con esta
situación y llevó a varios implicados
ante la justicia
pero claro digamos que el señor
kolomoisky no se lo tomó nada bien
prometió vengarse y esto es lo que dijo
públicamente del gobernador sakashvili
cuando un perro sin bozal muerde a
alguien
tenemos que castigar tanto al perro como
más importante aún a su dueño ahora
no penséis que misa se limitó a
denunciar a los oligarcas para nada
y
el choque de trenes
[Aplausos]
las reformas de saakashvili no de esa no
acababan de dar resultado muchas eran
frenadas e incluso saboteadas por el
propio gobierno de kiev esto ya no era
una cosa sólo de los oligarcas lo cierto
es que la corrupción en ucrania está tan
extendida amigos que a veces cuesta
diferenciar entre las mafias y las
propias autoridades
misano se lo pensó dos veces y puso al
gobierno también en su diana muchos
analistas dicen que en buena medida esta
nueva guerra contra el gobierno
respondía sobre todo a su ambición de
dar el salto a la política nacional es
probable que así sea pero el caso es que
lo hizo comenzó denunciando en
televisión la corrupción del mismísimo
primer ministro
arseni yatseniuk siguió con varios
ministros y terminó con su viejo amigo
el presidente petro poroshenko la
persona que lo había puesto al frente de
odessa poroshenko o yanukóvich quien más
da quién les va a robar en una situación
en la que el presidente ampara a dos
clanes 1 criminal formado por asesinos
de los años 90 y otro de corruptos yo no
quiero estar callado y estoy harto de
todo esto mijaíl saakashvili si el
idilio entre estos viejos amigos no
había durado mucho como hemos visto
poroshenko nombró a misa gobernador en
mayo de 2015 apenas un año más tarde la
batalla estaba servida
finalmente a principios de noviembre de
2016 misa presentó su renuncia como
gobernador de odessa y montó su propio
partido político
lm ene efe y ojo porque pronto superó
los 20 mil afiliados así es el georgiano
ahora quería dirigir los destinos de
ucrania en sus propias palabras su
aspiración era convertir a este desastre
de país en toda una superpotencia
europea ni más ni menos pero puede que
os estáis preguntando por la respuesta
de poroshenko y del gobierno a toda esta
campaña pues mirad en julio de 2017
aprovechando que milla se encontraba en
eeuu el gobierno ucraniano le retiró la
nacionalidad del país y le prohibió
regresar de repente mijaíl saakashvili
se convirtió en apátrida es decir en una
persona sin país ahora bien si pensáis
que eso detuvo a saakashvili estáis muy
equivocados mira cuando le quitaron la
nacionalidad misa se trasladó a polonia
hay que decir que en europa del este es
un personaje basta
he querido de hecho fueron varios los
países que le ofrecieron su nacionalidad
pero no me satén y ha decidido regresar
a ucrania y eso es precisamente lo que
hizo a pesar de las advertencias de kiev
el pasado 10 de septiembre rodeado de
una multitud de partidarios cruzó a pie
la frontera entre polonia y ucrania las
imágenes de cómo pasa sobre los guardias
fronterizos son tremendas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por cierto que pensáis que hace ahora
que ha regresado pues a pesar de
encontrarse en una extraña situación
legal misa está de gira por el país de
gira política claro ahora bien dicho
todo esto hay una pregunta clave que nos
queda por contestar y que estoy seguro
que muchos de vosotros os estáis
haciendo porque mijaíl saakashvili
[Música]
la revolución de saakashvili
veréis en 2003 misa lideró un
levantamiento popular contra el corrupto
sistema político georgiano liderado por
eduard shevarnadze y ojo porque llegó a
ocupar el parlamento georgiano en lo que
se conoció como la revolución de las
rosas a partir de ahí se convocaron
elecciones y saakashvili y literalmente
arrasó
comenzó entonces un vertiginoso proceso
de reformas una fiera lucha contra la
corrupción y una política dura hacia
moscú que se convirtió en un modelo para
muchos países exsoviéticos pero amigos
de todo esto y también de la leyenda
negra de saakashvili de su parte menos
glamourosa que también la tiene os
hablaremos en otro vídeo próximamente
aquí en visual político de momento turno
para ti
crees que misa acabará dirigiendo los
destinos de ucrania déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha gustado el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte al canal
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Aplausos]
[Música]